foreign
y calling from Dallas Texas hey Amy
welcome to the show
thank you hey how can we help
I've had a should be relatively quick I
think but um I've been investing now for
about 13 maybe 12 years and I did my
calculation I have about an eight
percent return so far should I be
discouraged by that or should I kind of
think you know we're in kind of a
downturn and overall it should end up
still being cut
well good job with that 13 years are you
completely out of debt
yeah baby step seven awesome oh that's
awesome so what is your net worth as of
today
uh 2.2 million I think maybe I think
you're going to be fine you know I think
you're gonna be I wouldn't be
discouraged with a 2.2 million I asked
George because one percent when I look
when I'm 65 is a
I mean a one percent swing you're saying
under over if you get nine percent
instead of eight percent it changes the
numbers drastically Yeah by like 15
million dollars and so you're worried am
I going to have enough
is that really the heart of the question
that's not that's not really the
question really the question is because
Dave says numerous times I should
average 10 to 12. well it's not that you
should it's just if you look at the S P
500 since you know the 1920s and 30s the
average return has been now there's been
times where it's been down 30 percent
there's been times where it's up 30 and
so I would not be discouraged by looking
at a snapshot of even 12 years and
looking at that because you're investing
over more like a 30-year period right
true and even a 30-year period getting
eight percent you're still going to be
wildly wealthy comparatively to if you
didn't invest
sure and so I I don't I don't look at it
in snapshots because you're right if I
looked at my 401k for the last year I'm
gonna throw up when you see negative 16
negative 18 it hurts your heart when
you're like I'm dumping money into this
and the number is going down it's going
the opposite way right
yes and so I encourage you to you can
look at it every so often but the fact
that you're here with a 2.2 million net
worth at what age are you
33 at 33 years old is mind-boggling
my husband's 32. yes how did you guys
get there because most people are going
is Amy crazy because she's saying she
should she be discouraged and here she
is with two million dollars at 33 years
old
um I mean I I like to say I did the baby
steps and I really did it's okay I was
never I was never in baby step two I
never had any debt okay great you just
avoided that completely and what age did
you start investing
as soon as I got out of college 2011.
okay and that was 12 years ago and
beyond that has anything else changed
did you get an inheritance
no
this was all just 401K your house your
cars
yes sir what do you all do for a living
uh surprise surprise we're both
Engineers love it love it hey how are
you invested right now what are you
investing in
um so right now it's a mix between
personal residence 401K
um my company stock which I am
diversifying
um just gradually
um and obviously Roth IRAs so and are
those in mutual funds index funds
um I mean many mutual funds
um I don't yeah I mean
ETFs sometimes but not for I mean it's
still I do 10 you know track record over
10 years and all the all those things do
you have an advisor a financial advisor
I do I do that's why I'm like wondering
it's always my fault right I'm not going
to blame him but I'd like should I make
any changes
well I mean it wouldn't hurt to get a
second opinion we've got great
smartvestors if you want to sit down
with them you can find them on the
Ramsey Solutions website but it is nice
to sit down just to double check to make
sure that they're investing your money
well
have you thought about getting a second
opinion
yes and you know obviously I I'm always
learning right so I'm always and it's
you know as we said it's him giving him
advising me and I make the final
decision so it's always my choice of
what I am investing and obviously I
don't ever invest in anything that I
don't actually understand
so that's why I'm well if you want some
encouragement just look at history you
can go look at charts of the S P 500
over the last you know Decades of years
and I'm looking at it right now and I'm
saying okay actually out of the last 12
years we were only down two years and
here's what you're looking at 2022 we
were down 18 which is skewing your
average number isn't it exactly and I am
like I am an engineer so and so 20 years
from now we're gonna have way more up
years than down years if you just look
at it historically and that's going to
change that average number so I wouldn't
focus on that average number and lose
sleep over that specific number because
it's not really an accurate
representation what we're trying to tell
people is over the course of time your
entire career your money is going to
grow at a significantly higher rate than
if you don't invest or you invest in
something super volatile gosh this is
such a great question though way to go
Amy that's amazing I love just the level
of ownership you have over and the fact
that you're continuing to ask questions
I'll just anybody anybody at 32 who has
2.2 million dollars is just incredible
those would be the people going I'm a
little discouraged by my eight percent
return I'm like that's the kind of
nerdery that will lead you to wealth and
keep it way to go awesome